It's a big world, full of difference and diversity.
How you see others is influenced by your own cultural perspective...
...and how others see you is influenced by their cultural perspective.
What happens when you speak?
Do people from other cultures understand you in the way you intended?
And what happens with different cultures in the workplace?
How rigid or flexible is their approach to rules?
Is formal or informal behavior expected?
And how do different cultures approach timekeeping?
To be a savvy global traveler,...
...you need to be willing to undertake the journey of understanding other cultures.
Develop cultural intelligence so you can communicate confidently across cultures.